[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is new
york times national correspondent fox
butterfield he joins us to discuss his
recent book all god's children the
basket family and the american tradition
of violence
[Music]
fox butterfield what is all god's
children about
it started out as a story about a young
man named willy basket who as a boy
murdered a series of people on the
subway in new york
and when i began to look into his record
i found that his father had also been
convicted of murder
and then i found that his grandfather
and great-grandfather had also been
violent criminals and eventually i
traced the family back to a county in
south carolina which has long been known
to historians as being one of or perhaps
the most violent county in the country
so where i started out looking at one
young boy in harlem i ended up really in
a way with a history of violence in
america
and it opened up a way to
understand violence in a very different
fashion than we normally do
that violence does not grow out of the
causes that we usually associate it with
it turned out murder is not something
new that
grows out of our cities
i didn't have anything to do with race
or with poverty or with the broken
family or with television
in fact it had a very different origin
the high homicide rates that
characterized the united states
really
have a geographical origin in the white
rural pre-civil war south
yeah ask you first about this
person right here this picture who is
this that's willy um he as a boy of 15
he murdered several people on the subway
in new york and before that he already
had a kind of legendary criminal record
he had committed by his own count 2 000
crimes including 200 armed robberies
later as an adult
when he was in prison he continued to
commit crimes in prison he attacked his
guards he threw feces on them
bit their fingers and in one case
stabbed a guard in the chest with a
homemade shank
where is he today today he's in a cell
in a prison in central new york state
it's actually the most solitary
confinement of any prisoner in the
entire country
they have built a special cell just for
willie the guards actually call him
hannibal lecter
as like the character in the movie uh
you when you go to the prison you have
to go through the regular prison and
then you have to go through the normal
solitary confinement block then you go
through another set of doors and gates
and then you come to the area where they
have willie he's kept in a kind of
plexiglas cage
it's all the iron bars are covered over
with extra heavy plexiglass so he can't
throw anything out or bite his guards
he's not allowed to have
books
newspapers magazines um there are you
can't listen to the radio or watch tv in
fact there are four tv cameras kept
trained on him from outside his cage 24
hours a day even if he wants to take a
shower or go to the bathroom to keep him
under watch
and the guards are not supposed to speak
to him it's really total solitary they
they even removed the light fixtures
from the ceiling of his cell because at
one point he took to eating the light
bulbs to show how violent he really
could be
how many hours have you talked to him
i think i spent over 300 hours talking
to willie where uh in
they they set up an arrangement so that
when he's in his cage you can be just
outside his cage in a very small area
uh within the within the larger cell
block
and you have to talk through some really
sort of pinprick size holes in the
plexiglas which are covered over with a
couple of layers of heavy wire mesh that
you would use to protect against
raccoons have you ever been the same
room with him right no you can't you no
that's not allowed uh i've been you know
six inches away from him but he's on the
other side of the partition
and how old is he today willie today is
33. uh he is
despite his enormous record of violence
he can be personally very charming he's
very smart his iq is near the genius
level
his father
amazingly is the was the only inmate in
american history ever to graduate from
college five beta kappa while he was
incarcerated his father actually earned
a straight a average from the university
of kansas
with a joint major in computer science
and psychology while he was incarcerated
at leavenworth federal penitentiary is
this a picture here of willie that's of
willie when he was defending himself in
one of his many trials actually where he
had stabbed a prison guard
why did he defend himself
willie thought he made a very good
lawyer in fact several judges
complimented him on being a remarkable
guard a remarkable uh lawyer the the the
picture on the top is willie arriving at
the courthouse to go on trial they're
having to pull him out of the van uh
with shackles on him he didn't want to
go into the courthouse he he always acts
in as a as obstreperous a way as he can
it's to live up to his reputation as
being the most violent inmate in new
york state or american history how many
people did he kill
well he's only been convicted of killing
two people he acknowledges that he
killed several more than that
and he
in the incident in the prison he
narrowly missed killing the guard
that's a picture of willie when he uh he
finally got when he was a boy and
convicted of murder he was in prison
until he was 21 then he got out for only
a couple of months and he was rearrested
for an assault and robbery charge and
that's a picture of him at 21 when he's
been just been picked up on the assault
and robbery charge that's a picture of
willie uh in his late 20s in the
visitors room at one of the many prisons
in new york state that he's been in
but he's in prison in that picture where
was he born well he was born in harlem
he had a
a normal delivery and and uh as a child
uh what what was exceptional about him
was that at first he was very bright
second
that he always seemed to be getting in
trouble and his mother couldn't
understand it
but she did frequently when she looked
at him
he reminded her of
willie's father of her husband
and she would say to willie willie when
you grow up you're going to be bad
you're going to be real bad just like
your father she didn't at first tell him
what his father had done
she wanted to protect him from that
terrible truth so willie's imagination
ran wild and he began to wonder what his
father had done and when he was about
six he saw a picture on his
grandmother's dresser of a man in prison
fatigues and he asked who it was and his
grandmother said that's your father he's
in prison he killed two men
and so willie in a rather perverse kind
of way thought this was great his father
you know was the baddest man you could
be that's a picture of willie's father
butch basket while he was at leavenworth
at that time doing time for a federal
bank robbery charge
did willie and his father butch ever
meet no they never met um
and amazingly they they looked very much
like each other people who knew them
both the relatives always said that
willie looked just like his father they
were both incredibly smart they had a
lot of mannerisms that are alike the way
their eyes look the way their mouths
work
but they never met they did
the first time they ever got in touch
was when willie had been arrested at the
age of 15
for murder and he was in a juvenile
prison
and
the warden in effect arranged for willie
to get in touch with his father
how
well initially there was there was a
strange coincidence
willie didn't know where his father was
he only knew this legend that his father
was a murderer and then the new york
daily news ran a story on the front page
identifying willie's father as a man in
prison in new york state
and willie wrote to the man thinking
gosh this is my father and he was very
excited
turned out to be a man with the same
name
as willie's father but it was a relative
another man who was also in prison for
murder
but who was a cousin of willie's father
and he wrote back to willie and said i
can find your father i think i know
where he is and he
that other man got a letter to willie's
father at leavenworth willie's father
then finally got in touch with him if
you spent 300 hours with willie basket
what are your impressions of him
and what kind of things did you talk to
him about
well the first thing that surprised me
was
how smart he is i spent a lot of my
adult career working that's willie as a
small boy
and the bottom pictures of willy with
one of his teachers in a in a reform
school when he was a small boy
willie was incredibly bright incredibly
charming when he found out i'd worked in
asia he began quoting to me from ho chi
minh and mao zedong and it wasn't just
jailhouse rhetoric he was quoting
quite accurately
at the and when i talked to him about
what i was trying to do to understand
why he was so violent
uh he got enthusiastic about the project
he said that he would like to cooperate
and the reason was because he had a
niece at that time she was seven named
danielle
who was very bright also but he was
beginning to get in trouble
she was
playing hooky at school she was staying
out from home she was being sent to the
family court even at the age of seven
and willie was worried she was going to
follow his path
and he thought maybe if i could
understand what had happened to him why
he was so violent it might in some
fashion save her
so he gave me the records that he had
collected over the years his juvenile
criminal records his psychiatric records
things that normally would be sealed and
that a writer researcher would never
find he gave
he provided to me
and then i set out to try to find his
family and when i would find information
i would come back usually and and tell
it to him
we talk it over
do you have all those
300 hours on tape no i couldn't take a
tape recorder into the prison uh it was
all you know pen and paper where's the
prison located the prison is in the cat
skills it's in a place called woodburn
oddly it's it's not a maximum security
prison but it's where they could build
the most secure confinement area just
for willie
what has he done that
requires this maximum security cell this
cage that he's in
while he's been in prison it wasn't just
what he did on the outside is what he's
done in prison
uh he
every opportunity he got he was waging
what he called a war
on his guards it was a war with the
system
he thought that the criminal justice
system was like a surrogate mother
because he's been locked up since he was
nine years old either in a juvenile
reformatory or an adult prison
and so he sees all the guards as his
enemy and he wants to prove that he's
the toughest meanest guy there ever was
so when he had an opportunity he would
throw hot coffee on a guard or he would
throw feces on them or if a nurse was
giving him his medication sometimes he
would bite the nurse's finger as i say
one time he actually pulled out a shank
and stabbed a guard
how did he get a shank in jail that's a
good question uh so what he actually did
was he removed a small rod from
underneath the typewriter that they gave
him to type up one of his legal cases on
and he he ground down the point of the
rod from under the typewriter and it was
like a very large ice pick which he
somehow managed to
secret under the bottom of his foot
and
he was being taken from his cell it
wasn't the same cell that i was saw him
in but a different cell at that time to
the visitors room
and he was supposedly frisked but the
guards didn't frisk the the bottom of
his foot they took off his shoes and
looked in his shoes they forgot to
pad the bottom of his feet
so he went into the visitors room where
he was actually being interviewed by a
young journalist
during the interview he
said i've got a shank and he went out
and he pulled the shank out
and walked up behind a guard and stabbed
him right in the chest did he kill him
no he just he just missed if the
very luckily uh if the uh if that ice
pick size rod had been a little thicker
he would have killed the guard because
it missed it came within half an inch of
his heart as it was the guard almost
bled to death it was a terrible incident
and this was a man he didn't even know
in fact he'd never seen the guard before
he didn't know the guard's name there
was no personal animus it was just what
willie said was his war with the system
and has he read your book he has read my
book now it was one of the few things
that i've been able to actually
get to him or give to him was this was
the book i wasn't sure that he'd be able
to receive it
and i couldn't hand it to him i had to
take it to the prison that had to go
through
official clearance by the prison but he
has read it has he given any reaction to
it he says he believes the stories are
accurate
and
he says that i've told the truth which
is as much as i can hope for will he
ever be out of that cell no i seriously
doubt he certainly will never be out of
prison he has three
uh life sentences which are tacked on
one after the other and he also now has
about 70 years in solitary confinement
which is something given to him by the
prison system rather than by a judge
and he will probably remain in that cell
forever is this a good idea
a good idea
all you've learned in this is a good
idea to have him
that confined
um i think that i mean eventually if he
could go say five years without any
incidents of violence
uh maybe this the prison system would be
willing to consider putting him back in
what they call general population
uh but in a very strange way willie
doesn't want that
because that would undermine undercut
his reputation of being
the the worst prisoner ever
and he lives on his reputation
there's so many names excuse me if i get
the wrong sequence and all that but is
it willie that swallowed the toenail
clipper yes will he swallow the toenail
clipper he
at various times and while he's been in
prison he swallowed lots of objects
the tops of pens or the pens themselves
toenail clippers razor blades light
bulbs
this was a way either to show how
violent he could be or an effort to get
himself out of the cell or the prison he
was in and get transferred to a hospital
ward where he thought maybe he could
have a chance to escape what happened
exactly on the toenail clipper thing
because i know he the toenail clipper
eventually worked i mean
eventually they took him to a hospital
ward they x-rayed him they saw where it
was in his bowel and eventually it
actually he was able to pass it through
and came out did he get what he wanted
to out of swallowing it uh to the to the
extent that it gave him some measure of
satisfaction and proved how tough he was
yes but nothing else it's a similar
story you tell about his father butch
who was in prison and wanted to escape
and use salt explain that story his
father after
many years of being in prison
really tried to go straight he worked
very hard to get a college degree to get
an education although he'd never been to
school really as a boy because his
father too
had been
locked up at the age of nine in fact
both willy and his father were sent to
the same reform school
at exactly the same age nine
and his father spent all those years
locked up
but as an adult he began to get an
education and he found that he was very
good at school and that's a picture of
butch at leavenworth receiving his five
beta kappa degree the first and he
remains the only inmate ever to graduate
phi beta kappa from
from college while in prison so
butch finally got out he he used his
education as a way to get out the
prison system felt that he had been
rehabilitated
and he got two jobs not just one he got
one job working in an aerospace company
as a computer programmer this was in
milwaukee he also got a job teaching a
course at the university of wisconsin
for computer science for undergraduates
he seemed to be doing well and then
suddenly he was rearrested it was a
charge of sexually assaulting a young
girl he said he was innocent but he
despaired
and he plotted with the girl's mother
who claimed that butch was innocent
and he resorted to an old prison ruse
that if you swallow enough salt it will
cause a kind of ulcer in your stomach
and make you cough up blood
um the garlic get the salt
he saved up enough salt from these
little packets that they provided with
his lunches and he swallowed them all at
once and he did then cough up blood and
the prison authorities didn't know what
had happened so they took him to a
hospital
and it happened to be
kind of an unguarded hospital
and he then arranged with his girlfriend
to come in disguised as a nurse
she was a white she was she was a white
woman who was a beautician and she uh
she came in she put on a nurse's uniform
and she brought two guns in she managed
to disarm the sheriff's deputy who was
guarding butch in the prison i mean in
the hospital room
and they got the handcuffs off of butch
put them on the sheriff's deputy chained
the sheriff's deputy to the wall and
then they took off and they would have
made a clean break except for a small
irony when they
they turned out of the hospital room
they turned to the right instead of to
the left if they'd gone left and gone
down the stairs they would have gotten
right to his girlfriend's car which was
sitting there
but because they they went the other
direction when they came out they were
on the wrong side of the hospital a huge
hospital complex and they got lost they
wandered around for a while by that time
the sheriff's deputies were alerted that
he was on the loose
so the sheriff's deputies closed in
and
butch used all the bullets that he had
to shoot out with the sheriff's deputies
except the last two when he realized he
was down to his last two bullets
uh he took the gun and put it to the
head of his girlfriend and killed her
and then he put it to his own head and
shot himself what year was this uh that
was 1985.
who is butch's father butch's father was
named james
james had been born in south carolina
was brought to augusta georgia as a
young boy grew up very very poor
and him
turned to a life of crime
as a young man when his marriage wasn't
working out
his
james
had married a woman and they'd had a
child butch
james
walked off and abandoned that child
really at the age of just a few months
and then in a terrible turn of events
the mother also abandoned the butch when
he was a
tiny little really still a baby
and butch was left to grow up on his own
largely on the streets of augusta in a
very poor section of town
who took care of him he had a
grandmother who would take care of him
but he
in a way nobody was taking care of him
because his grandmother had to work she
was a laundress for a white family and
he was left alone during the day he
would go out and beg and he soon joined
a gang
uh he would rob stores and we know from
the records that are preserved that by
the age of nine he actually had a
gunshot wound in one leg and he had a
case of gonorrhea this was diagnosed by
a doctor his father james did what then
his father james took a took a train
north from augusta to to washington
and uh
began robbing stores and uh was
eventually was caught and put in prison
a number of times for armed robbery
how did he
how did he die
uh in the end he died he died probably
it's not quite clear but probably died
of alcoholism died of liver uh
trouble with his liver from alcohol when
he was in his late 50s
and who was his father his father was a
man who was called pud basket who in
some ways is the most interesting member
of the family pud was born in 1889
in a little town or outside little town
in south carolina
and his his family was sharecroppers his
father had been a slave
and pud grew up in the 1890s which in
many ways was the worst decade for
afro-americans in american history it
was a period which we remember now for
lynching it was the height of flinching
it was a period when the jim crow laws
were imposed segregation and when blacks
lost the right to vote and there's a
picture in here of a hanging in the town
where uh
pud was brought up that's one of his
cousins
who was hung there the first man to be
hung in in that county
and pud was at the hanging
uh what's his real name kud's real name
was clifton what was put a short form
well it was pudding was what it was it
was a nickname that he was given from
the time he was a boy uh he never got
any education the family was was really
dirt poor sharecroppers he went to work
uh
farming a white man's land and
he became very resentful of the way his
family and and blacks were being treated
and
where he worked the white farmer would
still whip his hands this was still
legal in south carolina 30 40 years
after the end of the civil war it was
kind of a vestige of slavery and one day
pudd got tired of that and he turned
around as the white man was going to
whip him and he grabbed the whip from
the white man's hand and he said don't
step on my reputation
and after that
he could never get another job because
no white person wanted to employ him
so he began robbing stores and got put
on the chain gang but instead of
becoming an outlaw he became a kind of
folk hero to other african americans in
that community
there was a period that there were a
number of such sort of
black bed men heroes that were
springing alive all over the south these
were the people who were celebrated in
the early blues songs it was a period
when when african americans were really
uh
in deep trouble because of this crisis
of lynching and the jim crow laws and
and poverty and racism
and one of the few avenues that they had
was the sort of thing that that put did
whatever happened to him
put uh after this life of robbing
stories and being on the chain gang when
he was out at one point he was uh
carrying moonshine liquor from a still
and selling it
and uh he was actually working with a
white man and the white man was driving
the car and
actually teaching trying to teach pud to
drive and that they were drunk it was a
sunday morning and the car crashed and
the two of them were thrown out of the
car on a dirt road
and by when they were found they were
lying there by the side of the road
one had his neck broke and the other had
his head smashed in but between them was
an empty
jar of corn whiskey they had drunk it
down to the end and that's the way they
died what year was this
that was 1924
and at that time put had a little boy
james
whose mother then took him from the
rural south carolina countryside into
augusta georgia which was the nearest
city to try to find some kind of job
because she couldn't support them she
couldn't work as a sharecropper herself
women just weren't given the land and
weren't considered able to do the work
let's go back over the list again willie
is alive and in prison in new york
willie's the only one male male member
of the family who's alive he's in he's
in new york in prison and his father
butch died in the shootout with
sheriff's deputies in milwaukee 1985
and and butch's father james died he had
been
grown up in the south
and and then the great grandfather pudd
who had been born in 1889
in south carolina and had become really
the first
uh man in the family to get in trouble
with the law uh he died in 1924. he was
pud's father pitt's father was a man
named aaron
who was born a slave
whose family had been bought and sold a
number of times who is himself as a
young slave boy was bought and sold
several times
and i was very lucky to be able to trace
uh the family back that far and actually
back to aaron's father
uh who
had been probably born in
in maryland
somewhere maryland or virginia we're not
quite sure where and then sold off as a
very young slave boy and put into what
was called the long distance slave trade
was sent in a couple with other slaves
chained up and ended up being sold in
south carolina
and the family was bought and sold three
or four times
at one point one of their owners was a
man named basket
which is where they got
their surname from from the white slave
owner later they were sold to
a man named francis pickens who actually
became governor of south carolina and as
governor led south carolina into
secession
was the governor who ordered the shots
fired on fort sumter the subtitle of
your book is the basket family and the
american tradition of violence and i
wondered if
that's the reason that you
talked about this violent act
well that this is a preston brooks and
one of the most famous incidents in
american history preston brooks was a
congressman from south carolina from
this little county called edgefield
and
in 1856
he was very upset when this famous
senator from massachusetts named charles
sumner who was leading abolitionist gave
a speech in which sumner excoriated
south carolina for upholding slavery and
also attacked one of
brooks's relatives who was a senator
from south carolina named butler
this was offense to the family's honor
and honor was incredibly important to
southerners in the 19th century so
preston brooks thought this over and he
wanted to avenge his family and his
state's honor
so he walked over from the floor of the
house to the senate it was at noon time
and he's
unfortunately there were some still some
ladies in the visitors gallery and so as
a matter of honor he had to wait till
the ladies left
then he walked up to
senator sumner's desk
and he and preston brooks had a
gold-headed gutta-percha cane that was
walking stick he used because he'd been
wounded in a duel in the knee in an
earlier duel in south carolina
and he went up and he began flogging
senator sumner right on the floor of the
senate and flogged him so hard that he
left the cane just in shreds and sumner
was left largely paralyzed
brooks
resigned his seat went back to south
carolina but he was unanimously
reelected
in fact some local merchants bought him
another cane and they inscribed it hit
him again
and but for a lot of people in the north
this was regarded as the first act of
the civil war this the attack on sumner
was was seen as a you know a vicious
criminal act what year 1856
and charles sumner was massachusetts
charles sumner was from massachusetts if
you anybody goes to boston today and
they drive from the airport into the
city they have to go through the sumner
tunnel and that's where you live now
that's where i live now so you there's a
local reminder in boston of of that
incident right there the sumner tunnel
where the traffic always gets stuck how
did you find your way to boston
uh well i've worked for the new york
times for now 27 years
i worked a lot of that time in asia
but i'm as an adult i started
my family moved to boston and i consider
boston my home
and i'm lucky enough now that i have a
job where i can live in boston and work
for the new york times i have a national
assignment writing about
sort of the causes of crime and violence
and what do we do about it what
countries have you lived in in the world
well i was
i lived in taiwan as a as a graduate
student studying chinese and then i
began working there for the new york
times i was in vietnam for three years
during the war i was in japan for almost
three years i was in hong kong for four
years and i opened the new york times
bureau in china in beijing in 1979
after we normalized relations with china
how many books have you written i've
written two books on my own a previous
book on china
which was called china alive in the
bitter sea
you're also listed as an author with
neil shan and ew kenworthy and uh
hedrick smith on the pentagon papers
right i was i was one of the four
reporters at the new york times who
participated in the pentagon papers
project which is now actually we're
coming up on the 25th anniversary
um in the in the spring of uh 1971
um hedrick smith i mean i'm sorry neil
sheehan got the papers
and uh this was the secret history of
the vietnam war that
secretary mcnamara had committed
secretary of defense mcnamara had
commissioned to be done within the
defense department
which which included lots of secret
documents
and we began pouring over these and
eventually produced a series of articles
and you may recall that president nixon
was rather unhappy about this and he
moved through the court system
eventually went to the supreme court and
temporarily stopped us from publishing
where were you born
i was born in the south i lived in
virginia as a boy
actually my father was teaching at
william and mary in williamsburg in
those days williamsburg was a very small
town it's gotten a lot bigger since then
so i kind of i grew up in the old
tidewater virginia rural south in the
days of segregation where'd you go to
college um when i was just at the end of
high school my family moved to boston my
father got a job teaching in harvard and
i actually ended up going to harvard
what'd you study
oddly enough i studied chinese history
and went on in graduate school and
studied some more and but
ended up becoming a journalist instead
of
teaching as a professor myself why
journalism
uh i i found that i was spending too
much time in the library in that sort of
the dusty stacks doing research and i
wanted to get out and have a more active
life
but why you know the new york times and
writing
is there any influence in your life that
took you in that direction
well i'd always i'd always enjoyed
reading newspapers and some of my
friends said to me you spend so much
time reading newspapers you ought to
work for one
what about your parents what influence
did they have on you i think my father
had enormous influence that i didn't
appreciate at the time my father was an
historian an american historian and he
was his heroes were thomas jefferson and
john adams and my father was always
taking us around old houses or
battlefields
and teaching us to go back to the
beginning of things to to see where they
came from
and i realized as i was doing the
research for this book when i started
with young willy basket as a 15 year old
on the streets of harlem and wanted to
find out why he was so violent and why
america was so violent i began going
backwards in time and eventually in this
book i've gone back all the way to the
american revolution in south carolina
you dedicate your book to elizabeth
ethan sarah and sam who are those my
family elizabeth marin who's a
journalist for the los angeles times
uh ethan
sarah and sam are my three kids how old
are the kids
ethan is 19 sarah is 16 and sam is about
to be six any of them thinking of
journalism
uh
not so far
you would you encourage them to go into
journalism
uh i might i they the older two uh
clearly want to do something very
different than what their father did
sam's too young to know better
go back to the first moment that you
knew about willie basket
what year
actually i was sitting in the newsroom
at the new york times in in new york
minding my own business when an editor
came through
uh
the room and she walked past my desk and
she dropped some notes on my desk and
she said here's a story i'd like you to
do
was about willie who was at that point
on trial for stabbing the guard
in prison
and she wanted me to try to find out why
he was so violent he at that time he was
representing himself as his own lawyer
and he'd given a rather extraordinary
speech in the courtroom
describing himself as a monster created
by the system
and
in his opening statement to the jury he
acknowledged that he had stabbed the
guard in fact he took pride in it he
said there's no question that i did it i
did it the question he said the thing
that you need to look at is why did i do
this
well he tried to turn it around and put
the criminal justice system on trial
this is a picture of willie in fact
acting as his lawyer during that time
when he's shouting at the judge he did
several times he did a very good job of
defending himself and in one case he
actually got himself off
um
it was it was an instance where he got
in a fight in a courtroom
with the court officers and had attacked
them
and
they had they'd finally secured him but
it happened in front of a judge and the
district attorney and a number of
assistant district attorneys lots of
other witnesses
but willie actually won that case and
got off wow
uh he simply was very clever
and he
he was a he was a better lawyer than the
judge was a witness in the case when the
judge was called to be a witness willie
was able to in essence trick him out of
the testimony that he should have given
what was the date
that the story was dropped in your lap
in the new york times newsroom i was all
the way back in 1989 so i worked on the
book really for six years how did you go
about it
well you know when i started i was very
reluctant i didn't i did not want to
glorify a criminal i was very concerned
that some journalists who get involved
with criminals end up
turning them into saints or end up
trying to go to the parole board to help
spring them out of prison and i didn't
want to do that
also i'd never been in a prison in this
country and my own background was in
asian studies i'd spent 15 years living
and working in asia
but when i went there and i saw how
articulate willie was and that he had
these records that were available that
you normally wouldn't get
i thought there might be a story to do
and
i began looking into his background and
then i learned about his father having
also been convicted of murder
and having been sent to the same reform
school at the same age
and it seemed like a very powerful tale
which might help us understand why we're
in this predicament we are today now one
of the surprise things is that when you
look at crime rates now uh most crime
rates in the united states are not all
that different from those in western
europe the countries that we usually
compare ourselves to
uh there's more burglary in london now
than there is in new york
uh there are more car thefts in france
per capita than there are in the united
states
but in murder we're off the charts if
you look at young people in this country
young people commit homicide at a rate
60 times that
of young people in england and there's
there's something very wrong there and
if other crime rates are that close why
do we commit so much
uh violence so i
as i went back in this story
i found an explanation going way back to
into south carolina into the early
history of the country what is the
explanation well i think the explanation
has a lot to do with what uh white
southerners in the 19th century called
honor
it was our reputation it was a notion
that your person derives their worth
from the opinion of others so that if
somebody insults you or your family
you have to take action white
southerners in the antebellum south did
not believe in going to court andrew
jackson's mother and andrew jackson was
born in the western part of south
carolina she once said to him when he
was a boy a true gentleman does not go
to court if somebody insults you you
always settle them cases yourself
and in fact we know that in in the south
that among the upper classes this notion
of honor led to dueling
in south carolina dueling was outlawed
in 1812 but it continued on in fact the
the code book for duelists in south
carolina was written by the governor of
the state
uh in it he said that
he deplored the christian doctrine of
turning the other cheek
he said that because
such forgiveness is utterly repugnant to
human feelings this is a picture from an
old illustrated magazine of the
consequences of a duel
dueling stopped in the north but it
continued on in the south
into and after the civil war
i say that this governor of south
carolina uh actually wrote the
code book for duelist
and uh
he said that turning the other cheek was
a a notion utterly repugnant to human
feelings
because mere words can never be
satisfaction for words
among among the less affluent less
educated they had
honor led to an uh
a game that they called rough and tumble
or a savage form of what was known then
as wrestling
and the object of this was to chomp off
your opponent's nose or ears or even
chew off their fingers or gouge out
their eyes
again this practice was outlawed in
south carolina back at the early part of
the 19th century but it continued
uh and they they they made it a capital
crime uh but only if
you gouged out the eyes or chewed off
the fingers the nose and the ears were
okay
you say back in the uh notes on sources
that much of the voluminous primary
material on butch and willie butch being
woolly's father is normally confidential
and it was a rare luxury to have access
to it how did you get access to it
first because willie had some of his own
records
his juvenile criminal records and some
of the psychiatric records and then
where there were gaps and there were
lots of them willie would write
letters of permission for me to apply
to get some of these from some of the
other
juvenile facilities where he had been in
fact he he cooperated with me in getting
some of his records from the new york
state division for youth that's the
youth justice agency
um he also wrote letters of permission
so i could get access to his father's
records
and under the freedom of information act
i got things like his the fbi records
the state prison records and i ended up
with
thousands of pages of documents which
normally uh we wouldn't be able to see
under the chapter willie um
chapter 16
you say these these three sources and uh
earlier you say willy's behavior in
prison 85 and 86 are taken from three
sources disciplinary reports written by
his guards the transcript of his later
trial for arson and assault at mid-state
prison and the transcript of a hearing
to determine whether willie was a
persistent felon
these three sources totaled nearly 3 000
pages did you read all 3 000 yes i mean
i had to
uh well i made xerox copies of them or i
got the origin you know the original
documents whatever whatever it was
so i've got uh
i've got a number of file cabinets
filled with the with these documents
200 people you interviewed yes
who are the principal ones that gave you
valuable information and all that well
some of the most interesting ones were
very uh
elderly people in south carolina who
remembered
back to the 1890s into the turn of the
century what for me was the crucial
decade in this whole process
where uh
black
southerners began to adapt some of the
some of these notions from white
southerners we were just talking about
honor we can come back to that
um but but a number of the people that i
talked to were in their 90s of several
people over a hundred
one man who was still living in the
house that his great-grandfather had
built at the time of the american
revolution and he remembered his great
grandfather if that seems possible this
was a man who was well over 100 himself
did anyone not want to talk to you
uh well there were certainly some people
who didn't want to talk to me but
in the end uh i'd say the vast majority
did did will he ever marry
willie was very briefly married at one
at one point in his life and he when
he's 21 when he got out of prison from
having been a juvenile before he was
rearrested he was out for about two
months he married a woman but they had
no children and he was back in prison
shortly thereafter and she later
divorced him where is she now
she lives in new york but he has no
contact with her did you have contact
with her i talked to her and to her
mother what about butch his willy's
father did he marry butch uh butch's
father uh married married a woman uh
named laura who became willie's mother
uh who lives in lives in harlem that's
that's butch in prison at leavenworth um
and willie's mother was a reluctant to
cooperate because this has not been a
happy life for her after all her husband
committed murder in fact she was with
him
when he committed murder in milwaukee
back in 1961 tell that story please
uh they had they had traveled from new
york uh
to the midwest which
uh was on parole at the time from a
prison sentence in new york
uh but he absconded from his parole and
was traveling around actually selling
pornographic pictures which in the early
60s was something fairly serious
but he was they'd run out of money and
laura was pregnant and he was also
trying to get a job
and when he was in milwaukee uh
he was down to his last few dollars and
laura was pregnant she needed something
to eat
and he went into a pawn shop and he
tried to sell the last few pornographic
pictures that he had and the man said
well i like these but i don't have any
money right now come back tomorrow
morning so butch came back the next
morning he walked in happily and said
you got my money and
the pawn broker said never seen you
before you know get out of here
and butch was furious
and he grabbed a knife he would later
deny it was his own knife but he said he
found a knife on the counter and he
stabbed the pawn broker in the chest and
there was another customer who'd walked
into the shop and he stabbed him killed
both men almost instantly
in this kind of rage
that having been insulted he felt that
his respect
uh had been called into question here
that they were they were insulting him
and this is where i find a a tie-in to
this old white southern notion of honor
just in the same way that white
southerners uh talked about honor and
reputation i think african-americans
picked that idea up in a way
and the the important point here is that
white southerners
is the attitude towards the law white
southerners saw themselves above the law
um uh honor and slavery gave them that
idea
but
blacks in the 19th century found
themselves outside the law they couldn't
go to court to seek redress because the
sheriffs the police the judges and the
juries were all controlled by whites
so their only recourse really was to
take things in their own hands
and this is what i saw happening with
with willie's great grandfather man we
called pud basket
when he got tired of the white man
whipping him and he grabbed the whip out
of the white man's hand and said don't
step on my reputation he was using that
same language that white southerners had
used
and uh his son james would later uh when
he would start to get in trouble would
use those same words reputation and then
respect how many different places did
you go to see
physically that either the prisons or uh
the maximum security cells
well william himself is in is in one has
since i've known him since 1989 he's
been in the same prison and in the same
exact cell now now since 89 he hasn't
moved at all did you go to the other i
visited i visited some prisons in in
wisconsin where his father had been i
also went to leavenworth where his
father had been and i went to a couple
of prisons where
uh
some inmates are now who had been in
prison with his father to talk about his
father one man who's still in a federal
prison in texas who had been one of his
father's best friends at leavenworth how
do you find the prison authorities
when you try to talk to them or you want
to talk to prisoners are they
cooperative
when they know what i'm doing they've
been i would say on the whole they've
been very cooperative as long as i don't
try to break any rules
um and i'm not not carrying contraband
and i'm just i'm there for an interview
and they they know exactly what i'm
doing
on the whole that people have been
extremely cooperative anybody in the
process want money from you in order to
talk to you well yes i mean
that's something that people put their
hands out and i've had to say i'm sorry
i can't do it did willie want any money
uh willie well uh when we started new
york state had the son of sam law
uh that was put into effect after this
one man had uh killed a series of people
uh in new york
and uh
that
the law was to prevent people from
criminals from profiting by writing
books or doing movies about what their
their exploits
um during the course of the book the
supreme court has
overturned that law new york state has
been trying to get another one in place
that would meet the supreme court's
requirements
um so when i started with willie i mean
he could not in any way receive money
and that hasn't been an issue with him
you told me before we just started here
briefly that abc has bought rights to
the mini-series yes just uh very
recently abc has agreed to uh make this
into a mini-series which obviously will
take some time how many different shows
do you think you'll get out of this well
i that that's up to them i really i
really have no idea they've they've
talked about a minimum of two shows what
do you think they what what do you think
attracts them to this
i hope it's because it's a very powerful
story which gets at the roots of
violence in america
uh that
this violence is not something that just
started in our cities recently that in
fact these very high homicide rates
which characterize american violence go
back
a long way
we we what we've what we're learning is
that the uh
these high homicide rates go back into
the 19th and even into the 18th century
perhaps the county where willie's family
came from edgefield um
had was a was a small county uh it's its
largest town was a village of 300 people
but in the 19th century it had a
homicide rate as high as new york state
today new york city today which is
flabbergasting when you think about it
that's edgefield county
in in south carolina in the area
just north of augusta across the
savannah river and part way up towards
colombia the capital is trump thurman
from this area yes indeed in fact this
is one of the great stories
strom thurman's father was a man named
jay william thurman who was the
prosecutor or district attorney or he's
in south carolina they call him the
solicitor
for edgefield county in 1896 1897
and uh one spring day in 1897 when when
j william thurman was sitting in his
office at the courthouse
a a traveling salesman came by and
began berating thurman the traveling
salesman was drunk
and he was insulting thurman all about
his politics and he called him a liar
and a scoundrel this was an affront to
honor this was this old southern notion
of honor
and so thurman reached into his jacket
pocket and southern gentleman in those
days always had their jackets tailored
with a pistol pocket inside he pulled
out his coat revolver and he shot the
man dead on the spot
and although thurman was the
district attorney for the county he was
put on trial for murder
but the jury acquitted him in 35 minutes
because he pled self-defense it had been
an affront to his honor there's a clear
violation of that code
um
and the at that time the political boss
of south carolina who was also from
edgefield was a man named pitchfork ben
tillman
uh well
the sort of the first populist racist
governor
uh antecedent to george wallace and
there's a pitch a picture of uh
pitchfork ben tillman who boasted to the
end of his days that he said he would
always say i am from edgefield
as if that explained everything
and
at that time tillman was very powerful
he'd been governor and then senator
and he went to the president of the
united states
and he got the president to make
j william thurman the u.s attorney for
south carolina as a kind of reward for
having been charged with murder
um it was murder was no bar to high
office
in those days in edgefield it was
if it was committed in the name of honor
it was
it was acceptable
in the state of new york had there been
capital punishment at the time of
willie's prosecution would he be dead
today
uh if new york was executing criminals
he almost certainly would
uh new york only last year as you know
uh restored the death penalty that
during the time when willie was
committing his violent acts there there
was no death penalty in fact a lot of
prosecutors and politicians uh used
willie as an example of an argument for
restoring the death penalty
uh they would say willie is a walking
talking advertisement for the death
penalty
how much does it cost to keep him alive
a very great deal i mean in the cell
that the way they've got him now it's
it's well over a hundred thousand
dollars a year it's a it's a very
expensive proposition
uh you could send a lot of kids to
college for that much money when he
killed who did he kill
he killed several people that he didn't
know who poor people actually hispanic
people on the subway in harlem
they were people that he was attempting
to rob as a 15 year old
and when they moved
and he thought they were resisting him
or that they were dissing him as kids
now say he shot them
um how many
uh he was convicted of killing two he
was also convicted of attempted murder
of a third but he almost undoubtedly
killed several other people that he was
simply not charged with because there
was no proof how did he get caught
he got caught because he did it too
often and the police began developing a
profile of of who he was and he he
discarded one man's wallet near his
house and
the police put two and two together and
did a very good job
it was in the early days of the use of
computers and they figured out probably
who he was he had a record of committing
lots of other robberies on the subway so
they knew his name and where he lived
and when they picked him up
he actually
admitted
that he'd done this unintentionally but
he admitted it he was boasting of it in
a way
willie had made it his mission in life
from early on when he found out what his
father had done to make himself the most
violent criminal that he could this is
one of these very surprising things
which i
which i came on in the research you know
we well most of us know that if your
father is a doctor or a lawyer or a
farmer policeman when you grow up you're
probably going to go into their line of
work what doesn't occur to us because we
don't have that experience is
that if your father is a violent
criminal who's been in prison that also
is going to have a very powerful if
perverse attraction for you it's exactly
what happened with willie when he found
out his father had was a violent
criminal in prison for murder willie
wanted to emulate him in fact he began
telling his teachers and his schoolmates
don't mess with me my father was a
murderer when i grow up i'm going to be
just like him where did you get the name
all god's children came from willie's
great great grandfather it was a saying
that he had
probably from an old spiritual
and he was
referring to the fact that everybody who
lived in that county really owned part
of it even though he'd been a slave and
hadn't been able to own land uh he too
was from edgefield if we'd have seen you
in peking or in
hong kong or in taiwan and somebody said
fox butterfield in a couple years you're
going to have a book on the basket
family what would you have said then i'd
have been very skeptical
why
because i thought i was going to go on
writing about asia and was interested in
living and working in asia
um what changed that well partly was i
wanted my fam my my
my two older children were born in hong
kong i wanted them to see their own
country i wanted to come back here and
then once i came back here
i began to feel that the the
problem of violence was something that
we didn't understand very well
and uh as somebody who grew up in the
south i
i remember it as a boy a lot of stories
that uh
uh had something to do with violence i
couldn't put all these pieces together
um
and i i was when i came home after uh
years abroad and saw this violence i was
very uncomfortable it it seemed in a way
as if i'd come back to a to a to a
different country it wasn't the country
that i remembered
um and so i wanted to try to figure it
out and i then i then i hoped that this
uh study this book would be a way to get
at that
how hard was this to write
the research was always very interesting
it was intellectually challenging to try
to track down the people some of them in
their 90s or over 100 who'd lived some
of these stories people who'd witnessed
hangings back in edgefield at
the turn of the century even before
that was a interesting reporting but the
writing was very very difficult
because i knew in the end what happened
to these men and it was very sad and
very tragic and awful and it was
terrible for their victims too i i don't
want to
here to suggest for a minute that
um you know that these people were not
responsible for what they did clearly
and willie had choices along the way and
he he made his choices although
he would probably tell you that they
were compulsions
where do you write
i wrote the book at home in a little
office in my house which is outside of
boston
if we saw you there what's what's around
you
uh
lots of file cabinets and this floor
littered with piles of paper that i
could never put away what do you write
on or where right on a right on a
computer
um
and uh
i i ended up with so many footnotes that
the computer wasn't accepting them
anymore
how would you characterize the whole
process of writing easy hard
well the hardest that was very hard some
days to get up in the morning and want
to sit down at the computer because
the story was so sad for everybody
but in the end i felt that there was an
important point here about where
violence comes from in america
and so i wanted to tell that story i i
wasn't a sense of mission but i felt it
was important
to get it out that this is violence is
not something that grows out of our
cities in fact there's some good news
here which we haven't talked about and
that is that we go back and look at
violence in this country
um
we we know now that we're not nearly as
violent as our ancestors were there are
some very good recent historical studies
in england and holland and germany and
italy which show that violence in the
middle ages was 10 times worse than it
is now the rate of homicide in london
and chaucer's time was 10 times what it
is in in current london
and there what from the 15th and 16th
centuries onward there was kind of a
civilizing process
as the power of the state grew and court
spread people didn't have to settle
disputes out among themselves they had
another way of doing it and in the 19th
century
this process really sped up with the
industrial revolution as people went to
work in factories they had to be more
disciplined to answer to the foreman the
bell or the whistle the spread of public
schools in the 19th century institutions
like the ymca sunday schools
all these made us a much more orderly
people so we now know in fact that in
our big cities in this country like new
york or philadelphia
boston the homicide rate in 1960 was
only about half what it had been in 1850
so for a full century our cities were
getting safer did you like willie
um well i have i would say it's an
ambivalent relationship i mean i uh
he's very charming he's articulate he's
smart he can be funny
but you also know how violent he is and
you know what he's done and that's not
very likable
our guest is fox butterfield and this is
what the book looks like in a picture of
willie on the cover all god's children
how old is he in this picture
he was 15 at that time
thank you for joining us thank you very
much
[Music]
[Music]